to chat with their general manager joe
douglas afterwards if you could just
tell us that
what that was like yeah great staff love
those guys and
you know joe douglas is a great guy and
it was you know good to see him out here
and
um you know they got a good thing going
and uh you know my zoom interactions
with them has just kind of been like any
other team you know trying to go through
and
and you know they're just trying to pick
your brain and see what you're about you
know
you process things and all that kind of
stuff so it's been good
breaking news the nfl now drafting
middle schoolers to play
quarterback in the nfl you know you're
getting old when incoming rookies look
like they are younger than your nephew
who's 14.
joining us now a guy who played in the
nfl from 2005 through 2015. he's our
good friend chris candy chris welcome
how are you pal
i'm doing pretty good i appreciate you
having me on the show mike it's been a
while since we had a chance to chat
yeah i remember the old days when we we
would do it from time to time in the
afternoon i think you'd hop the train
up from baltimore you'd come up on your
off day right
when you were still playing for the
ravens weren't you doing that
no so i would do that during the bye
week but in the off season i lived in
the tri-state area so i would just drive
from my house in jersey
up to stanford but i was doing pft in
the afternoon with you guys
two or three times a week yeah i thought
there was a time you came out
i thought yeah i thought you and and
despite being involved with me
you've been quite successful i just
thought there was one time you came up
on your off day but
i i i'm clearly incorrect i'll defer to
your knowledge of your life
instead of my own vague recollection but
those were some fun times and some fun
days well now you're getting it done
focusing on the new york teams and i'm
going to start with zach wilson
i miles and i were talking about this
earlier the trade today that has the
49ers move up to number three and give
up two other first round picks
and a third round pick they're not doing
that for anything other than a
quarterback
and i think they know or at least they
expect that the jets
are going to take zack wilson at number
two and they're content with that and
they have another guy
that they want what was your read on the
49ers moving up
and what that means as it relates to the
jets especially in light of the report
that the 49ers never talked to the jets
about moving all the way to number two
well that was the big surprise for me
mike the fact that the 49ers didn't have
any communications between the jets it
kind of felt like the jets have tipped
their hand to the rest of the league
that they're going to take a quarterback
and it makes all the sense in the world
because you have a lot of questions
about sam donald's
through three seasons if for no other
reason you get an opportunity to reset
the money at the position
reset the clock and if you look at the
landscape of the afc east
it seems like it's going to be a couple
of years before the jets are going to
have the opportunity to compete so
it makes sense to go a different
direction with quarterback and
just feels like everybody around the
national football league already knows
chris why has have things gone so wrong
with sam darnold is he as bad
as we all seem to perceive that he is or
is
it an adam gase thing or why is it
that they were just so ready to move on
well miles here's the thing i don't
think
anybody knows whether or not sam
donald's any good and that's the problem
because we're through three seasons and
we still can't make a definitive
determination on what the kid is he's
got more turnovers than he does
passing touchdowns so that's a problem i
remember my former coach bill parcells
used to always say
i'll give a player three years to show
me what it can do and then i'm gonna
make a decision on him well
unfortunately we've gotten to three
years with sam
and we still have no clue as to what he
is now in all fairness to him the
organization hasn't done him any favors
they fired his head coach after his
rookie year they fired a general manager
that drafted him going into his second
year
and then to make things worse chris
johnson the brother of woody johnson
decided to saddle sam darnold with adam
gates the
quote-unquote quarterback whisperer
after he was an unmitigated disaster
down in miami so
a lot of things have kind of gone
against sam donald but
that still doesn't answer the question
as to whether or not the kid can play
quarterback in the nfl
but you're right about the three years i
think in this day and age
three years if you don't declare
yourself to be a franchise quarterback
within three years you're not going to
eventually
the the great ones they're going to
stand out
some way somehow despite who the coach
is despite who the teammates are
you're going to see something out of
that guy in his first three years
to let you know he's a guy that you keep
for as long as you can and what have we
seen
from darnold to make us say wow he's the
guy you know there hasn't been
a patrick mahomes type of a moment that
he gave us right away where we say
wow this guy's for real and i think
that's the problem
back in the 70s you had five years to
figure it out now you got three years
and
chris i i feel bad for sam darnold the
way it's gone and he'll get an
opportunity somewhere not in san
francisco apparently but he'll get an
opportunity
but for a team that's been trying to
find a franchise quarterback really
since joe namath
you know you got to do it you got to
take your shot because
if it works you got your answer and if
it doesn't
you'll be back again in two or three
years to try again just like the jets
are
no you're right and if you're joe
douglas do you want to go down with
somebody else's pick at quarterback
or do you want to go down with your own
guy i mean you can make the same
argument about the decision to move on
from adam gates
and go with rob salah it's like he makes
his first head coaching higher
and then being able to pair that head
coach with his future franchise
quarterback so from his career mortality
standpoint like i just think that joe
douglas has made the decision
i'm going to make the decisions and if
it fails it's on me
as opposed to failing with somebody
else's people
so christian you just mentioned rob
solid do you think that him bringing in
mike lefleur who is matt lafleur's
brother who's had that success
in green bay and also knows that
shanahan's system so well
does that make people feel a little bit
more comfortable about drafting
a quarterback you know at two overall
and then having to develop him
yeah i think it makes joe douglas and
this new regime feel a little more
comfortable because that shanahan
system is user friendly when it comes to
quarterback play
right you have the the zone running
scheme and then you pair with a lot of
boots
and sprint actions and so being able to
get a young quarterback
outside of the pocket away from pressure
away from being behind or shaky
offensive line i think it makes a whole
lot of sense
and it allows that young quarterback to
truly grow into that role so i think
it'll cater to a lot of the strengths of
the young quarterback that they decide
to take it to whether it ends up being
zach wilson trey lance or justin fields
all of them are athletic quarterbacks
all of them do a great job of being able
to throw on the run so
i just feel like that's a good direction
for this jets franchise to go in
now it's just a matter of picking the
right quarterback and supporting him
properly
there's justifiable skepticism about the
jets generally because of the way things
have gone lately though
what's the mood locally right now given
the moves they've made
given where they are given that it's
kind of settling in on zach wilson
as the guy how are people feeling in new
york about what could happen for the
jets
surprisingly mike people that are around
town are split
between the jets deciding to take a
young quarterback at two or staying with
sam donald they feel like they can get a
haul
for one of those teams that's
quarterback starved that wants to move
into that number two slot
because of all the reasons that we've
already outlined they feel like sam
donald
just hasn't gotten a fair shake and they
want to put a good supporting cast
around the kid
to see whether or not he's got the goods
the only problem with that is this
if sam donald proves himself not to be
your guy
you're going into the 2022 offseason
with with ammunition but might not
necessarily have the quarterbacks
in that draft class to be able to pivot
from sam donald
so it just seems like it makes the most
sense right now if you're going to try
to
find your next franchise quarterback for
the next decade plus that you would do
it this offseason you would do it in
this draft
do you feel like there is a spot that
the jets don't
have to address going into this draft
after free agency what do you think that
they've kind of taken care of at this
point
well i like what they did at the
receiver position i think they're solid
there they have a lot to build on i mean
they added corey davis
to denzel mims and and jameson crowder
and they've also got um
some other pieces that they want to get
a look at but uh i like the keenan cole
pickup i think he's going to be great in
the slot form so
i think the receiver position is one
that they're solid but outside of that
they need everything else i mean i like
their left tackle makai beckton
i like winning williams their defensive
tackle but i mean they they really
need help at pretty much every other
position so i think that this jets
team is a work in progress and this
rebuild
is going to take a couple of years we're
not talking about a turnaround after one
season i think it's going to be two or
three years down the road
before the jets are truly competitive in
the afc
you won a super bowl 10 years ago as a
member of the new york giants the team
has been to the playoffs all of
once since then what
do they need to do and how do you feel
about what they've done this off season
they've been aggressive they've spent a
lot
over 100 million in combined contract
value for two guys who played to combine
eight games last year i don't know how i
feel about that
how do you feel about what the giants
are doing well i think the giants have
positioned themselves well for the draft
late april right they've addressed the
glaring needs on this roster they got a
number two corner
they made sure they locked up leonard
williams they probably should have did
that deal as soon as they traded for
leonard williams
they probably could have done it for
about six million dollars a year cheaper
um had they went that route but but i
like the moves that they made bringing
in kenny galladay
a true number one receiver an
ex-receiver somebody that can
that can be that big body target for
daniel jones with those 50 balls as well
as
um being a a friend to him in the red
zone i like the kyle rudolph pick up
um it seems like they're going to go the
route of trying to have two tight end
sets
but the thing that i really love the
most about the moves that dave gettleman
has made
is that it seems like he's trying to
eliminate all the excuses for daniel
jones
as to why he can't be a successful
quarterback in the nfl
going into year three this is a huge
year for him daniel jones has got to
prove that he's the guy
otherwise the giants are probably going
to pivot off of him and they're probably
going to move on from dave gettleman
do you think that he is the guy
well he's got to stop turning the
football over miles i mean 39 turnovers
in two seasons ain't gonna get it done
it's hard to be
a consistently competitive team when
your quarterback is turning the ball
over
20 times a year so i think that's the
part that he's got to get cleaned up now
the thing i will say
is this offense started to look
different in the second
half of 2020 as jason garrett
incorporated daniel jones into some of
the zone
read schemes with their running game and
i think that took a lot of pressure off
of dj in the passing game
so we'll see if they're able to continue
with that once he's fully healthy once
he's past that hamstring
but um this is a big show improved year
for daniel i mean
i root for him as much as anybody
because he went to my high school so i
want to see the kid have success
but i mean this thing could go one of
two ways but the giants are
are eliminating all the excuses for him
so i think that they're trying to set
the table for him to have a huge season
getting saquon barkley back uh i mean
this is this is one of those things
where daniel jones has got to put up
or he's going to be moved on hey it's
just like sam darnold
year three what do we see year three for
josh allen we saw a superstar
it's going to break one way or the other
for daniel jones this year
he's got to work on that clock in his
head holds the ball too long
ball gets knocked out but it's it's not
something that isn't fixable it's up to
him to fix it
speaking of clocks you were telling us
before this segment
you get up at 2 30 in the morning for
your 5 a.m to 8 a.m show on espn
new york good lord chris canty
i know right i guess being on time
coughing time during my playing days
comes in handy for something but uh yeah
it is an early morning this is uh going
on my third month
on that schedule and when i first
started out the people that were in the
business said
don't worry give it some time you'll get
used to it well three months obviously
ain't enough time to get used to it it
still hurts every single morning i get
up
well i i had a show that started at six
for five years or four years and that
was hard
seven is still hard i can't imagine
starting at five
can't imagine getting up at 2 30. but uh
we'll let you get some rest you're
probably ready for bed after a full week
of getting up at 2 30.
appreciate your time very much let's do
it again real soon chris great talking
to you pal
all right sounds good thanks for having
me on mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports